who is the best director you ever worked  with Martin Scorsese why is Scorsese so  good explain it to me who is a novice  it's uh you like chess right yes okay so  imagine if you can make the most complex  chess move with no clock right right  that's like in other words I could think  about it you have four hours to make  your move right okay you still are a  brilliant chess player  now imagine you make an even better  chess move than that brilliant chess  player but you do it in 30 seconds with  the clock going his choices are quick  definitive and right his CH What It  Takes a brilliant director who is not at  that place yet possibly right even I'm  talking someone a master let's get a  chess player a master director  it takes him he can fix that problem  it's Advanced problem fixing right and  problem solving in 30 seconds you  literally watch him close his eyes and  then solve an insanely complex issue  which directing is just solving issues  constant